well folks it happened now that gas  prices are falling and they're falling  significantly and they're falling fast  for over five weeks now fox news is  worried are gas prices falling too fast  our mom and pop gas stations going to  get screwed because of it they're not by  the way gas stations make very little  money off gas and they make it whether  gas is high or low in fact you could  argue it's better for gas to be low for  them um all of a sudden now  the white house is talking too much  about the fact that gas prices are down  which biden certainly shouldn't be  getting credit for these people are  pathetic they're predictable and they're  pathetic